what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
yesterday's
loki finale was absolutely insane there
was a lot that was answered a lot that
was revealed but we're also left with
a lot more questions but luckily we are
going to be getting a season 2
and movies like doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness and spider-man no
way home are going to also help clear
some things up
so yes we have to wait for season 2 but
spider-man's going to be crazy and it
sounds like doctor strange is going to
be absolutely bonkers as well
elizabeth olsen has recently stated that
they really are trying to make
a scary movie and we recently got
reports that tom hiddleston's loki will
be
in multiverse of madness which is very
fitting since him and sylvia caused that
and we'll get into that but first thank
you to red magic 6r for sponsoring this
video we'll talk about them in a bit
but one big question that everybody had
at the end of the loki finale was
where did ren slayer go and if you
haven't seen the loki episode 6 finale
spoilers coming up so if you don't care
great if you do
bye wren slayer just yeted out of there
all she said was that she was going in
search of free will
it wasn't even really revealed if she
knew who he who remains
was although it didn't really seem like
it you never really know because where
did she go
well luckily we actually don't have to
wonder too much because
marvel themselves actually put out an
article explaining what had happened at
the end
the article is actually called loki the
truth about judge rinslayer and miss
minutes
and i'll break down this entire article
and talk about if rin slayer actually
knew kang
or he who remains or was she blindsided
as well
and where exactly did she go and set out
to do in the end when she left the tva
and if you're new and you want to stay
up to date on all things msu be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos
now this article released by marvel is
actually really cool because they tell
us what she's thinking that is not said
on
screen and it starts off by talking
about how when the series first begins
she's
very loyal and it's very black and white
the tva is good
everything else is kind of bad it's
their job to prune these other timelines
so they can protect the sacred timeline
and prevent a multiversal war and the
tva actually did a good job at that they
protected the sacred timeline there was
only one
no branch timelines were created and
there was no multiversal war
as soon as sylvie killed kang it all
just went crazy
and as kang slash he who remains said
the tva
works and boy was he right because as
soon as he was gone it all went into
madness
and this article goes on to tell us that
ren slayer believes in the tva
even if it was kind of created by a lie
it still works
one paragraph reads she has the making
of a very complex villain that has her
own set of principles
and beliefs that drive her she doesn't
believe that what she's doing is
evil she believes that the mission is
for greater good and renslayer probably
wishes that she never learned that the
timekeepers were fake
that they had just been able to keep
doing this forever and that's from the
head writer michael waldron and we see
this actually play out on screen
mobius says that i think the people are
ready to hear a little truth you know
like the tva is a lie but ren slayer
immediately replies but what if
it's a necessary one in this scene right
here the article reads that
red slayer is desperate especially when
mobius and hunter b15 are kind of
starting to show everybody that the tva
really is a lie
they continue to explain she's the good
soldier of the tva just
a disciple to the bureaucracy then it's
revealed to be a lie to her
instead of that galvanizing her and
making her question her life's purpose
the way it did with mobius rinslayer
wants to stay in power
she reacts more in anger and this is
actually one
key of why she left and this is where
they explain
what she's up to they say that the idea
that pretty much everyone in the tva is
a variant and that there are other
variants of rinse layer in different
times
that was kind of mind-blowing to me and
this is umbotha raw speaking who plays
rinslayer in the mcu she continues to
say
we just dipped our toe into this at the
end of the show but you realize that the
multiverse
is just so epic the possibilities are
endless
there's so much potential for what's on
the other side of that
time door and ultimately she wants
revenge
with whoever put this whole facade
together as for her parting thoughts as
she disappears to parts unknown
she's thinking peace out by free
will i get free will now she wants to
find who pulled the wool over her eyes
that's what she's going to go out in
search of and they end by saying
she is a scary customer to be out there
in the multiverse so
we'll see what happens so in this
article marvel reveals to us
where rinslayer went she went in search
of the person that created the tva
as well verifying that she did not know
he
who remains in this article they also
state that she did not know that the
timekeepers were a lie
and the series actually made it pretty
clear that she spoke with the timekeeper
several times however of course we know
that it was he who remains that was
controlling them
or miss minutes but of course she works
for him now there are serious
implications of
rinslayer walking away to go and find he
who remains slash
king and i actually think that she
herself is about to become
a major villain as well and i'll explain
this in just a bit
but real quick thank you to red magic 6r
for sponsoring this video when it comes
to playing games on your phone the red
magic 6-r
is the ultimate gaming phone by a long
shot well when it comes to playing games
on this phone you get a 144hz
6.67 inch screen with a 360hz touch
refresh rate making basically anything
you play look absolutely incredible
and if that wasn't enough you get
quadruple cameras
meaning you're pretty much going to be
taking the best photos no matter what
setting you're in
you have a 64 megapixel main camera an 8
megapixel
ultra wide angle a 5 megapixel macro
camera and a 2 megapixel depth of field
camera
you have ultra fast dual independent
shoulder triggers with a response time
of 8.3 milliseconds
basically if you're a gamer and you want
a phone that's going to let you play
whatever you want
whenever you want and also be insanely
fast and have a super high quality
camera
you need to check out the red magic 6r
and you can do so in the description
down below
now the ending of the loki finale inside
of the tva can be a little bit confusing
this isn't an alternate timeline because
the tva exists
outside of time i'll definitely do a
video just
breaking this down but for the moment
basically what you need to know is is
that
kang came in conquered the tva and has
taken it over
now kang has definitely changed things
and he's definitely gotten different
variants of people and replaced them and
he's definitely brainwashed people and
erased their previous memories in a
different way
than he who remains did so basically
what you need to know is it's a
different tva and king the conqueror
rules this one and
marvel.com did confirm that that statue
at the end
is indeed kang so it's a different tva
one that ravana rinslayer was not around
for when it was changed
she is left to search for he who remains
however he's dead she'll eventually find
out that
this new kang is in charge of the tva
and that's who she's going to go after
however
it might go down a little bit
differently than she would expect
you see if you've been following my
videos or you're a comic book fan
you know that ravana rinslayer and king
the conqueror
actually eventually fall in love much
like loki and sylvie did and i still
don't care what anybody says i still
like that that happened but ravonna and
kang
don't start off being lovers in fact
when they first meet each other
kang's a pretty big jerk and in fact
that could be what
he who remains was referring to when he
said that he's been called
a jerk a conqueror you see ravana
rinslayer in the comics is a princess
and kang pretty much comes up and says
hey i demand an audience with you and
she's like what
no who are you who granted you access
here no get out of here and even her dad
the king is like
nah request denied but this is how kang
replies
silence you are merely puppet rulers and
you know that full well
king is the power here now and always if
you incur my displeasure i may not
permit you to one day rule the universe
at my side
ravana she replies with i'd rather die
and he replies with
that too can be arranged with king all
things are possible
then the avengers come and fight him and
kang pretty much destroys them with ease
like it's literally no big deal to him
at all
then kang says i've earned your marriage
by conquest so he's
kind of romantic i guess but ultimately
it doesn't matter because
eventually they do end up falling in
love with each other
and they become lovers and i'm
predicting that in season two we might
see a very similar story ravona will be
searching for kang and since he is the
one that created the tva
lie or at least a variant of him did
she's gonna be pretty pissed off
originally
however this new king has his own tva
and the variants of all the people
are still there perhaps he wants to use
the tva still of course for his own
doing
but use them nonetheless and perhaps
when rinslayer returns
she will see eye to eye with him after
all she did want the tva to stay
intact even though she knew that
timekeepers were a lie and i'm sure she
could get that free will that she'd been
searching for
if she marries kang and if this does
happen she would rule beside him
and given her philosophy in episode 6
she would probably rule just like him
maybe not as evil but she would still be
sending people to goliath because one
thing is for sure
the kang the conqueror that is coming
that is now in charge of the tva
is going to be extremely evil even he
who remains said
if you think i'm evil well wait till you
meet
my variants so a lot to look forward to
in season two
of loki but for now where did rinslayer
go
well she went in search of kang she
wants revenge on the person
that fed her this lie so let me know
what you think about this in the
comments down below
let me know how much you enjoyed the
loki finale and don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest news for live
updates you can also follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof